[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci d'être là pour une
autre émission envies de lecture voilà
flora tout et jacques toux fournier pas
tournier au fait du félix et corinne
déjà vous avez de nouvelles propositions
à nous faire de nouvelles envies à nos
données alors on commence par vous pour
changer pour flora qu'est ce que vous
nous avez apporté alors je vous ai
apporté à nouveau un album jeunesse
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours et puis
avec dans le cadre de la fête de la
nature c'est bien de pouvoir découvrir
la nature autrement à savoir un petit
peu plus avant après des balades en
forêt donc ça t'ouvre cet album jeunesse
s'appelle plantes vagabonde
il est écrit et illustré par et midi
vaste un pauvre et il présente aux
enfants la façon dont la nature se
renouvelle
souvent dans les albums jeunesse on
indique aux enfants qu'il faut planter
des petites graines les laisser pousser
et c est là on va voir comment la nature
se renouvelle de façon naturelle
d'accord par exemple lorsqu'on souffle
sur un pissenlit les graines symbole la
façon dont se renouvellent des fraisiers
en rampant ou encore l'art attention à
votre micro part peut-être que voilà
c'est mieux pour pour voir les images la
façon dont les graines peuvent rebondir
ou flotter et donc la façon dont les
plantes vont voyager d'accord sur
produire tout à fait voilà ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'illustrent les
illustrations sont assez minimaliste oui
elle ressemble beaucoup au flore
naturaliste d'accord c'est un livre à
découvrir avec les enfants à partir de 6
ans ou avec les plus jeunes s'ils sont
intéressés par la nature et je suis sûr
que les adultes apprendront également
menacé sur wii et en plus ça peut être
observez lui rend chaque saison puisque
c'est à chaque saison qui se passe
quelque chose tout à fait très bien
merci pour ce jeu les choix naturel et
vous alors jacques dites moi tout quelle
est votre choix
le choix s'est prêté à une fenêtre un
recueil de poésie de hala mohammad poète
syrienne traduit par antoine jockey est
publié aux éditions bruno doucey cette
année hala mohammad est une poète et
cinéaste syrienne qui s'est réfugié en
france pour fuir le boucher el-assad et
dash est donc là là rassemblés à un
ensemble de textes qui avait été publié
chez différents éditeurs ou liban
ce que le liban est le pays des grands
et des grands éditeurs de langue arabe
est donc ce livret est sorti et j'en
suis très heureux parce que c'est un
livre d'un d'une des grandes dames de la
poésie arabe actuellement syrienne
d'autant plus et les poètes syrien sont
trop peu entendue org on entend beaucoup
adonis mais il y en a d'autres et donc
voilà j'ai choisi ce livre là qu'il le
livre d'une dune exilés d'une femme qui
tout en pleurant tous les jours son son
pays et ce qu'elle a dû laisser là bas a
le courage d'écrire et de continuer à
vivre
alors si palm en place à l'est pas grâce
à l'écriture non d'accord et j'imagine
que ce cet auteur vous parle d'autant
plus que vous organisez une semaine
particulière oui elle a été elle a été
de nos invités sur la semaine des
écrivains persécutés en novembre les
année dernière elle a été invité deux
fois et je travaille avec elle
régulièrement donc c'est à dire qu'on
organise régulièrement des lectures à
paris et avec l'association l'union des
poètes pour faire entendre la voix des
poètes qui dans leur pays ont des
problèmes avec la censure
l'expression le voilà tout ce qu'ils ont
à dire et qu'on leur empêche de dire la
première à kayes c'est son deuxième
recueil en français parce qu'elle avait
été publié aux éditions al manar
lorsqu'elle est invité au festival de
poésie set et je ne résiste pas au
plaisir de lire un texte
allez-y j'allais vous le demandez la
fenêtre et l'invention des civilisations
la fenêtre un poème la fenêtre une
géographie démocratique la fenêtre un
texte contre la géographie de la
tyrannie la fenêtre un procès juste
m'écouter merci vous après cette lecture
plaisir refait les anneaux annoncé
choisir deuxième livre des petites parce
que parler de mémoire d'adrien qui
nourrit mais était bien un deuxième que
j'aime bien regarder de temps en temps
alors celui là j'ai vu que trois fois
ces années c'est un début donc c'est un
très joli livre et qui de mathias enard
qui s'appelle parle-leur de batailles de
rois et d'éléphants
c'est un tout petit livre on le lit en
deux soirées une soirée aux 2 qui
raconte en fait un épisode de la vie de
michel-ange
assez peu documentée il se trouve qu'ils
se disputaient continuellement avec le
pape jules ii son commanditaire qui ne
le paient jamais avec qui n'était jamais
d'accord et donc lors d'une dispute
comme ça il répondu coup favorablement à
l'invitation du sultan ottoman qui
l'invitent à constantinople pour
dessiner et construire un pont qui va
relier constantinople à paiera donc au
dessus de la corne d'or et donc il
arrive là et donc on suit ce cheminement
on suit sa visite dont constantinople
donc il ya plusieurs voies qui nous
parle il ya lui et à la voix du
narrateur et il ya une voix féminine est
donc tout ça s'entremêlent et c'est un
très joli vivant sur le
sur les descriptions de constantinople
c'est super et aussi sur la voie
intérieure du créateur puisque du coup
on rentre à l'intérieur de lui et on
comprend que créer c'est difficile c'est
du travail que c'est que ça ne vient pas
tout de suite que donc on passe par tous
ses états d'âme et puis c'est aussi
intéressant parce que ça esquisse le
portrait de michel-ange qui est quand
même finalement qui est un génie mais un
sale bonhomme
honnêtement c'est à dire que ils piquent
des crises il est sale
il est désagréable il il comment dire il
est à voir non pas un artiste justement
pas vraiment et animale voilà les
égoïsmes égoïste égocentrique avare les
patients peuvent bien faire relève pas
du tout sympathique et par contre il est
génial
voilà rien pour écouter commande est
estimée gainage
non on le déteste pas du tout en plus on
les aime à la fin quand même malgré
génial pour essayer histoire vraie dont
essaya partie c'est en partie c'est
comme un mandat drire dont on parlait
l'autre fois c'est à dire que il ya une
base historique qui réagit ensuite il ya
le travail
du romancier et l'écriture du romancier
voilà donc c'est ce commet pas un roman
historique parce que c'est pas tout à
fait ça s'est basé sur un fait c'est ça
bien un fait réel et puis ensuite une
partie romancier qui comble les trous
génial ok merci alors corinne est là moi
je vais vous parler aussi d'un récit
romancé
ouais
donc ça s'appelle la chamane blanche
c'est écrit par olga caritte il dit donc
qui est une psychiatre russe et qui nous
raconte son histoire en fait dans ce
livre c'est son histoire à elle c'est
son histoire elle donc en fait
l'histoire
l'histoire commence où elle raconte sa
vie et son métier de psychiatre
l'exercice de son métier de psychiatre
en russie là bas et suit en fait un
événement personnel et une situation
professionnelle elle est amenée à partir
en sibérie dans les monts de l'altaï où
elle va découvrir en fait et réalisé
tout un voyage initiatique dans des
lieux et auprès de personnages assez
mystérieux et notamment une chamane
blanche ans et est en fait tout le livre
est toute l'histoire raconte tout ce
parcours est tout ce voyage initiatique
elle fait aussi bien dans la géographie
de la sibérie mais aussi dans ses
voyages il dans ses relations avec le
monde des esprits c'est voyage dans le
temps les rencontres qu'elle peut faire
avec les différents personnages et et
ses différentes situations et l'intérêt
en fait
ou alors au delà peut-être dû du côté un
petit peu mystique 15 spirituel surtout
c'est en fait le aussi le suivi et le
parcours de cette scientifique vis-à-vis
de ces phénomènes un peu extraordinaire
donc au départ elle et on la sent
intrigué un peu curieuse très dubitative
par rapport à tout ce qu elle
vie et au fur et à mesure en fait l on
sent qu'elles adhèrent de plus en plus
et en fait malgré son esprit
scientifique on sent qu'elle est là elle
va elle va essayer de prendre les
différents livres expérience qu'elle
peut vivre pour les adapter en fait à
son métier de psychiatre et aujourd'hui
elle vit aux états unis
elle exerce toujours et elle utilise
quelques principes en fait de chamanisme
dans l'exercice de sa profession c'est
un vraiment un livre dans lequel on est
on est pris on se prend au jeu qu'on y
croit qu'on n'y croit pas peu importe on
se prend au jeu et c'est un très joli
voyage géniale et elle écrit d'autres
livres cet homme car at il dit c'est
marie pas ok bah écoutez merci beaucoup
merci à vous et c'est de nos vies de
lire tout ça alors on va remplir nos
valises pour l'été de tous ces
magnifiques t et et que se passe-t-il l
heure jacques bientôt cet été c'était au
mois de juillet les le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est emparé d'un événement
national qui s'appelle partir en livre
qui est qui a été initiée par le centre
national du livre et coiffes en iran ils
partirent en livres cd des opérations
qui sont proposés enfin proposé par des
médiathèques ou par d'autres équipements
pour permettre aux livres aux gens qui
principalement ne partent pas en
vacances
deux des activités avec et pour le livre
donc il y aura énormément d'événements
sur saint quentin en yvelines juste
après le 14 juillet
dont certains de ces événements auront
lieu à la commanderie à elancourt avec
les partenariats eux
des itinéraires politique de l'atelier
des sciences et et de déserts vivent des
arts visuels de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et alors est
ce que c'est aussi destiné aux enfants
c'est destiné à tout le monde c'est ça
qui est intéressant il n'y a pas que les
enfants qui partent pas en vacances il
ya les parents aussi
donc il y aura différents différentes
voilà il faut être attentif sur le site
internet de saint quentin et puis il ya
le programme ce rôle était là dessus non
au mois de juillet pendant une dizaine
de jours à dakhla 14 juillet ok génial
mais écoutez merci pour cette belle
envie que vous nous avez donné là et à
très vite pour recommencer merci bien
celle ci à voir
[Musique]